you need to calm down or don't because
Taylor Swift's 2023 Grammy's gown is
full of Easter eggs
from current music to past looks
the singer rocked an updo with a custom
two-piece midnight blue gown by Roberto
Cavalli with lots of glittering details
clearly a tribute to her newest album
midnights
and turns out the original dress
included a hood which is giving major
ready for it vibes
are you ready for it and die hard
swifties were quick to notice the color
yeah it's the same color as her fearless
era Grammy's dress in 2010. you know
when Taylor won her very first award it
feels like you know when you're in
second grade and you think about these
things that are just so far Out Of Reach
and and the Grammys are are words like
that you know and to actually go to the
Grammys is such an honor of the
two-piece look is also giving 1989 era
Taylor when she wore this pink and red
outfit by Oscar de la Renta and those
dramatic dangling purple earrings well
they're by Lorraine Schwartz and worth
three million dollars the sparklers seem
like a nod to her 2010 album speak now
I go back to December
which swifties think could be a hint
it's the next record she's re-recording
as far as my musical Direction goes I
would always like to keep people on
their toes in that regard I think that's
the best way to be exciting Taylor who's
no stranger to making history at the
Grammys scored four nominations at the
2023 ceremony
and there's the possibility that she
could get to her lucky number 13 total
Grammys
[Music]
thank you